el líder de la unión europea más cercano
al kremlin volvió a ganar las elecciones
en hungría la victoria del
ultranacionalista viktor orbán trajo
consigo la felicitación del presidente
vladimir putin
pese a una situación internacional
difícil el futuro desarrollo de los
vínculos bilaterales y de cooperación
corresponderá a los intereses de los
pueblos de rusia y hungría
orbán lidera una democracia y liberal
para muchos inspirada en algunos
elementos en rusia y aunque apoyó las
cuatro rondas de sanciones de la unión
europea contra moscú no colaboró con
armas ni permitió que los cargamentos de
material militar para ucrania de otros
socios pasaran por su territorio busca
la lectura rural mcchrystal y ahora
hemos tenido que luchar contra las
fuerzas más grandes la izquierda en casa
la izquierda internacional los
burócratas de bruselas todas las
organizaciones del imperio solos los
medios de comunicación internacionales y
finalmente el presidente ucraniano nunca
habíamos tenido tantos oponentes antes
[Aplausos]
walk además celebró elecciones serbia el
populista aleksandar vucic fue reelegido
putin también lo felicito espero que su
trabajo como jefe de estado continúe
ayudando a fortalecer las relaciones de
asociación estratégica eso por supuesto
beneficiará a los pueblos hermanos de
rusia y serbia
pese a solicitar su adhesión a la unión
europea serbia mantiene lazos económicos
con rusia pero también culturales e
históricos el 83% de los serbios
consideran a moscú como un amigo y cox
visto trataremos de mantener nuestras
relaciones no sólo correctas sino
también amistosas con la federación rusa
de la mejor manera posible con dos eso
los éxitos de los aliados de vladimir
putin marcan un nuevo camino para europa
donde hungría y serbia se debatirán
entre permanecer junto al bloque europeo
o acercarse más a moscú sobre todo ahora
con la guerra en ucrania en pleno curso